so welcome everyone i know we're like a
little late i'm so sorry uh this is
session 10. um
each speaker is going to get like about
10 minutes i'm going to give everyone
like a one minute warning that they're
running off
um
so in this session we have five great
papers
that do all
new things in the spirit of itcs
uh the first two are individual fairness
and advertising auctions through inverse
personality by shuchi chawla and meena
and unfairness and stability in
two-setted matchings by gili carney
guyroctom and galiona
and they are papers that
i would say offered new lenses on core
agt problems like at auctions and
matchings and the next three papers
are the nash bargaining based models for
magic markets one-sided and two-sided
fisher and arrow de brogle uh muay tava
hosseini and dj vazirani
then interactive communication bilateral
trade by jimin mao renee paisley and
kangding wang from duke
and the last one is multi-channel
patient persuasion by yaakov
iphone zoo and constantine zabarni so i
think these three papers offer new
models to
uh get around some possibility results i
had a couple more things to say about
each paper but since we're running a bit
late uh i'll just hand it over to
our first speaker who is uh mina
jegadeeson so mina if you can share your
screen
thank you
okay cool
you can see my screen
okay so um i'm gonna talk about
individual fairness in um advertising
auctions through inverse proportionality
and this is joint work with chujichala
um so there's been lots of evidence of
sku delivery in online advertising so
people from different gender and racial
groups can end up seeing differing
amounts of ads in sensitive categories
like housing and employment
um so before i dive into how these uh
sources of unfairness can occur i'm
gonna give a very simplified overview um
of ad options
so the idea in an ad auction is when a
user arrives on the platform bids are
collected so either these bids are
directly specified by advertisers or
done through some sort of automated
bidding system where the platform
generates bids based on advertisers high
level preferences
so after the bidding step um the
platform runs some sort of an auction
format to determine um which
advertisement to show the user
so some common ad auction formats that
are used are either a first price
auction where the auction allocates the
highest bidding advertiser and charges
them their bid or a second price auction
where the auction um out again allocates
the highest bidding advertiser but then
charges them their second highest bid
so um
what's a little surprising is that these
standard ad auction formats can actually
introduce unfairness into which users
see which ads
so the first source of unfairness is
that the advertiser targeting is unfair
so maybe um the advertisers bids uh
actually uh look unfair and this can
kind of be audited by looking at each
advertiser's spinning patterns in
isolation
the second source of unfairness which is
more subtle is that the platform's
allocation algorithm can create
unfairness even when the bids are fair
so even when each advertiser bids fairly
in isolation um so this has been
documented in various empirical studies
for example um in employment it's been
shown that there can be skewed delivery
in ads even when each advertiser uses
gender neutral
targeting and a similar phenomenon has
been shown for housing ads so in these
um settings unfairness arises solely
from the allocation algorithm
so our contribution is a fairness
framework that eliminates the unfairness
introduced by the platform so we focus
on the second source of unfairness um
and we build on some previous work
so to get some intuition for why um this
the platform can introduce unfairness
let's consider the following toy example
so consider two users alice and bob um
and two uh advertisers a big tech
company and a startup so let's say that
the big tech company and the startup
both place very similar bids on alice
and bob but maybe the big tech company
places a slightly higher bid on alice
and the startup places a slightly higher
bid on bob
so if uh us maybe the platform runs some
kind of standard um auction format to um
allocate the ad slots then alice will
end up seeing the big tech company ad
and bob will end up seeing the startup
ad so here the highest bid wins auction
exaggerated these small fluctuations and
bids so these two
users who receive very similar bids can
end up uh seeing very different ads
so we show that these fluctuations are
not just theoretical and actually can
occur on the yahoo ads data set so while
i'm focusing on um unfairness that can
occur within a category of ads um there
can also be unfairness from cross
category competition so in this work we
focus on the unfairness from a single
category but our results here can be
composed with results from existing work
to get these multi-category fairness
guarantees
okay so in our model um there's a
universe of users that arrive
sequentially and when a user arrives on
the platform uh each advertiser places a
bid on the user so we can think of each
user as associated to this vector of
values
the auction then allocates a single slot
per user um randomizing across the k
advertisers and we assume that this uh
our allocation algorithm satisfies a
weak monotonicity so it can be
implemented in some incentive compatible
way
so our contribution is at auctions that
do not introduce unfairness um and in
addition to fairness guarantees our ad
auctions achieve a constant fraction of
the social welfare compared to the
unfair optimal so this is the benchmark
of what um the maximal social welfare
that can be obtained in the absence of
any fairness constraints um and also
achieves uh near optimal trade-offs
between fairness and social welfare so
in this sense um
the first point shows that the cost of
fairness of these add auctions is not
too high and the second result shows
that these uh ad auctions are kind of
near optimal
okay so the way we formulate fairness is
as a stability constraint so our
starting point is individual fairness
which requires that similar users obtain
similar allocations um and we formulate
this fairness requirement as a stability
constraint so recall that we were
focusing on the second source of
unfairness where um the advertiser bids
have already been audited to look fair
in isolation so now two similar users um
should receive similar bids from all
advertisers so our stability requirement
is if two users have similar values from
all advertisers then they should end up
receiving similar allocations
so more formally
an allocation is value stable with
respect to a value stability constraint
if for every pair of value vectors the
following constraint is satisfied so
let's say that the two value vectors are
coordinate wise um at most an alpha a
multiplicative factor apart then we
require that the allocations are within
a
f of alpha additive factor apart
so we measure um closeness
uh with for values multiplicatively so
that this is like kind of a scale and
variant notion of closeness and we
measure closeness in allocations
additively to capture um the difference
in probability that uh the two users see
the ad
um and so this function f captures how
strong the um value stability constraint
is so in some sense how strong the
fairness constraint is
um and so essentially this guarantees
that the auction itself does not
introduce any further unfairness other
than what might already be present in
the advertiser values um so in this
sense we are focusing on that second
source of unfairness that i mentioned um
on the in the previous slides
okay so um our with this uh definition
arm in mind our goal is to design
value-stable allocation algorithms so uh
if we look at the standard at auction
formats then consider this highest bid
wins allocation where we allocate the to
the advertiser with the highest value
this achieves the optimal social welfare
um but it is not value stable
um so the issue with the highest bid
wins auction is essentially that the
allocation rule wasn't smooth so if we
consider proportional allocation this is
kind of the most natural smooth
allocation rule where we allocate
proportionally to the values um this is
value stable
but unfortunately the social welfare um
goes can go to zero as the number of
advertisers goes to infinity so the
approximation for social welfare in this
sense uh is very poor
so we design a family of allocation
algorithms that are value stable and
achieve a constant fraction with social
welfare regardless of the number of
advertisers
so um our solution is inverse
proportional allocation the key idea is
to deduct proportionally to the inverse
of the values so we start by allocating
the full ad slot to all advertisers and
then deduct uh proportionally to the
inverse of the value that that
advertiser places on the user um and
then when an advertiser hits a zero
allocation we kind of throw them out and
then continue with this process
so essentially
uh essentially we're setting t so that
um
the uh this equality is satisfied and uh
we show in the paper that t
can this can be computed efficiently
so we also generalize this to deducting
proportionally to functions of the
values to capture a broader range of
value stability constraints
so um our main result is that inverse
proportional allocation is value stable
with the following value stability
constraint and achieves the following
approximation ratio so in particular if
we set l to be one this achieves a
constant fraction of social welfare
compared to the unfair optimal we can
tune the uh fairness uh social welfare
trade-off as we change l
um and it also achieves near-optimal
trade-offs between fairness or value
stability and social welfare so
regardless of the value stability
constraint as long as it satisfies a
mild condition um there exists an
inverse proportional allocation
algorithm that achieves a near optimal
approximation ratio for social welfare
so in conclusion um we considered
fairness in ad auctions and design
adductions that don't create unfairness
in the allocation um and we designed we
proposed a fairness notion of value
stability um which guarantees that if
the values bids are similar then the
allocations are similar and allowed us
to isolate this source of unfairness
created by the platform and then we
designed this family of allocation
algorithms that achieve near optimal
trade-offs between fairness and social
welfare and our results extend a broader
notion of fairness
uh thank you
great thank you mina uh so while the
next speaker sets up so gilly is picking
up next
uh if there's any questions this is a
good time to ask i have a question
um which is if you've looked at
what would happen if you wanted to
allocate more than one slot in this
paper right you could imagine like a
similar water filling algorithm
like the one you proposed but instead of
uh you know having the constraint like
you had it would be equal to two so long
as you don't allocate more than one unit
yeah that's a great question so we could
like you can kind of like naively apply
this for every slot and uh get some sort
of guarantee but it's not clear that the
when you restrict to um
like the
there being one every ad being shown at
most once that this is kind of going to
be the right auction format um so in
this work we focused on like single ad
slots but um that would be like a very
interesting direction for future work
got it can you stop sharing it so that
gilly can transition thank you there we
go
uh
great so uh our next speaker is uh
gayley carney from the weights man she's
gonna tell us about fairness and
stability in two-sided matchings
gilly all yours i'll time you
hi
name is um and i will present the wall
conference and stability in two-sided
matchings
this is a joint walk with a guy rodbloom
and galiana from the weizmann institute
our walk focuses on the setting of
two-sided matchings proposed by garen
shapley
the objective is to find the full
matching between two sets of the same
size
as the running example we consider the
allocation of doctors to hospitals for
residency where each hospital is matched
to a single doctor
each doctor has preference over the
hospitals and each hospital has
preference over the doctors
for instance for this viral doctor the
preference is a yellow hospital then
blue hospital and then white hospital
similarly the yellow hospital has
preference over the doctors
we call this type of preferences ordinal
preferences and the goal is to find the
matching that is stable
a stable matching is defined by the
absence of blocking pearls where a
blocking pair is a pair of a doctor and
a hospital that prefer to be matched
with each other rather than with their
matched partners
consider this matching in this case the
valid doctor and the hero hospital form
a blocking pair and this matching is not
stable
this notion of stability was introduced
in the seminal work of galen sharply who
showed that stable matching always exist
and can be found efficiently
in our walk our goal is to find the
matching that is not only stable but
also fair to the doctors for example the
medic should not discriminate doctors
based on their ethnicity
even without formalizing defense
requirement in this context one issue is
that the preferences of the hospitals
might not be fair to begin with
suppose some hospitals discriminate
doctors from some ethnic group
in that case requiring a stable matching
might lead to a magic that is
discriminatory against that ethnic hope
however our hospital preferences is
enough to guarantee a fair matching
in this this work we show that even when
fair hospital preferences do not
guarantee a fair matching
and our main question is whether
fairness and stability are compatible
to begin we consider a limited setting
where we assume a simple firmness
constraint and fair hospital preferences
based on these assumptions we present
two results in the first result we show
that even under a strong fairness
assumption over the hospital's
preferences simply running the gail
sharply algorithm is not sufficient to
guarantee that the final location is
fair
in our second result we present an
algorithm that guarantees both stability
and fairness under these assumptions
this algorithm has a proposed reject
structure that is inspired by the gail
sharply algorithm
in the last result we showed that if the
assumptions are even partially removed
no girl sharply style algorithm is able
to achieve both fairness and stability
in order to show our results i will
first define what is our definition for
refer matching and for fair hospital
preferences
i will start by defining what is a fair
matching we assume the doctors are
partitioned into clusters where in each
cluster the doctors are similar in terms
of merit
our fairness requirements requirement
builds upon the approach of individual
fairness proposed by dwarf at all which
says that similar individuals should
have similar outcomes however we want to
take the preferences of the doctors into
account as well
therefore we use preferences informed
individual fairness proposed by kimit-r
which under the assumption of a
politician of the doctors into
similarity clusters means that within
each cluster the matching is envy free
that is every doctor prefers its own
allocation over the location of any
other doctor in the cluster
the problem is that since the number of
hospitals is limited a deterministic
fell matching might not exist suppose
there are only two similar doctors and
they rank the same hospital first since
they cannot both be matched with any
determination deterministic matching is
unfelt to one of them
this can be solved by matching each of
them to this hospital with probability
hairs
thus we would like to find a
probabilistic allocation that is a
distribution over matchings and our
reference and stability requirements are
a priori
next i will present our definition for
fair hospital preferences
we say the preferences of the hospital
are fair if the hospital has direct
reference over the clusters and is
indifferent between doctors in the same
cluster
the definitions i presented here are a
simplified version of the definitions we
use in the paper in the paper we also
define stability for probabilistic
allocation
now that i presented all the definitions
i will present the results
as a first step it makes sense to
require fair hospital preferences and
then to play the game sharply i'll go
with them to these preferences
a natural assumption is that if the
hospitals are not discriminatory the
matching won't be discriminatory as well
the question is how to run the gail
sharply algorithm over such fair
preferences
we use the probabilistic representation
of the preferences and sample them
the preferences are represented in the
distribution of the ordinal preferences
with the deterministic order of the
clusters where the order of the doctors
in each cluster is chosen uniformly at
random
we find the probabilistic allocation by
sampling this distribution of each
hospital preference and running the
gauge up the algorithm over the sample
preferences the probabilistic allocation
is the resulting random variable
we hoped the difference of the
preferences will imply feral location
but actually it did not in the paper we
showed two counter examples for the two
variants of the gel sharply algorithm
where the preferences of the hospitals
are fair but the resulting allocation is
not
this result joins existing works by
dwolk and dilvento the chose
failure of composition in fairness
that is even if the mechanism seems
unbiased requiring fairness from all the
participants is not enough to guarantee
a fair solution
however we do have a positive result
in the paper we show an algorithm fair
proposed and reject that under the
setting of a partition of the doctors
into clusters and sell hospital
preferences finding an allocation that
is both fair and stable the algorithm is
based on the structure of the gail
sharply algorithm
the difference is that the hospitals
decide whether to be matched to similar
doctors simultaneously
in a way that will maintain fairness
this is done by allowing the parties to
propose and accept probability mass the
algorithm does not always stop but it
does always converge thus we stop when
the solution is close enough to a fair
and stable solution
this is why the solution is
approximately fair and stable
al suggested formulating a fairness
requirement using the similarity metric
where distances are real values
the partition to clusters is actually a
simple case of a similarity metric for
distances between doctors are idle zero
for several doctors or one for different
doctors
but what about a general similarity
metric
in our last result we showed that if we
remove any of the assumptions that is if
we allow either a general similarity
metric or unfair hospital preferences no
algorithm of the style of the gale
sharply algorithm contains both fairness
and stability
we define a class of local proposing
algorithms with the seminal structure of
the gail sharply algorithm and to our
proposed and reject algorithm
these algo items are local in the sense
that there is no decision maker and each
participant acts upon their own
preference without being aware to the
preferences of the other participants
we showed that no algorithm in this
class can guarantee both fairness and
stability
to conclude we studied the problem of
finding fair probabilistic allocations
in the setting of the two-sided matching
problem
we showed that under a strong fairness
requirement over the hospital
preferences and over the similarity
metric a fair unstable solution can
always be found approximately using our
algorithm we also showed that if we
remove even one of the assumptions then
any algorithm in the style of the gel
sharply algorithm fails to guarantee
such a solution
that's it thank you
great thank you uh kylian so while we
transition to another speaker so uh
vijay is up next if there's any
questions for gili this is a good time
to ask
um
have you
so so i know that there's a lot of uh
experimental work on
matchings or you know
applied to like real
systems have you looked into this or
like into running like an actual
experiment just out of curiosity
in our research no but i know that there
are
there are walks about
relay allocations to doctors to
hospitals in israel but it's a bit
it's a the setting is a bit different
and they use a
different mechanism
all right
thank you very much
so our next speaker is vijay who
hopefully
will be able to share his screen
i think it worked
there we go but i have to
okay
okay
great
our next speaker is bj bazirani from uci
need to take it away
yeah so
uh i'm going to talk about
i'm trying to remove this bar from the
top okay uh i'm going to talk about
the matching markets
uh
uh one-sided and two-sided uh in both
fischer and arrow double settings but
all defined from a new angle
in this paper uh
the nash bargaining based models
so
so basically uh
oh this is joint work with uh
mustava
who's in the business school at uc
irvine uh
a very fine student who couldn't make it
to this uh
at this time because he's interviewing
so he asked me to give this talk but he
has given the half hour talk that is
recorded
and a very nice one that too okay so
uh so the models uh we are considering
here are those defined
using cardinal utility functions unlike
the previous models which were defined
using ordinal utility functions like the
gail shapley model
but here we are using cardinal utility
functions
and
these models suffer from two
deficiencies
the first one is the following and and
and here i'm talking about a very
classic mecha mechanism given by uh
highland and zig zaghouser
more than 40 years ago
79
and last year it was realized that it is
income
intractable so computing even an
approximate equilibrium for this model
is ppid complete uh
and their two works uh one of them gave
uh membership and the other uh hardness
so it showed ppad completeness uh
and and this is actually the most
elementary matching market that one can
think of because it's one-sided and it's
based on linear utilities so nothing
could be simpler
uh then hillen and zekauser did look at
a further model
namely
the aerodibru extension of their their
mechanism and realized that it does not
even admit any equilibrium so they gave
a counter example and that's where
things stood for 40 years
uh basically there's no other models
that we are aware of in particular no
model for two-sided matching markets
and that's a very uh
strange
circumstance because if you look at uh
general equilibrium theory it's replete
with models so many models fundamental
models that address highly specialized
and realistic situations and more
general situations and so
on so why why this paucity so so our
work is trying to rectify both these
flaws the intractability of hd
and the paucity of models
uh
and
okay so before i go into our work uh
it'd be important to
go a little bit deeper into healing the
causer it's a fantastic mechanism if you
if you really look at it i fell in love
with it for
for you know a very long time until the
interact abilities came about i was
really hoping that it because it's
it's really a
marriage between matching and the linear
fischer market both of which have not
only polynomial time but strongly
polynomial algorithms i was really
hoping that since it just combines the
two
uh it should lead to a polynomial time
algorithm but no it's highly intractable
um
so here we have a one-sided matching
market
um so for instance agents and goods and
only the agents have preferences goods
are dumb okay they don't have any
preference
over the agents okay so that's how a
one-sided matching market works
and uh
and and in particular we have equal
numbers of agents and goods and the
goods are indivisible so you really have
to find
a permutation between these two sets
and uij is a utility that
agent i derive from good j
and
of course we want uh
to not find any random uh
uh permutation of uh goods to agents but
something that's uh that has good
properties like at least pareto
optimality okay or nb freeness and so on
so
so hillen and the causer uh
go
you use the power of a pricing mechanism
to achieve these nice properties
uh like this what they say is that we
first make the goods divisible so we
have one unit of each code we'll think
of it as one unit of probability shares
then we give one dollar to each agent
and
uh we make the demand of each agent b
one unit of probability shares across
all the goods whatever they get okay and
then
we find equilibrium allocations and
prices of goods so
definitely prices of goods will emerge
through demand and supply considerations
and and people will receive different
probability shares of different goods um
depending on the prices of the goods
and everybody has exactly one dollar to
spend
okay
and this equilibrium this act allocation
will actually
uh be a fractional perfect matching over
the n agents and goods
uh
or the complete bipartite graph let's
say over in agents and edge and goods
uh
and and and the way but but remember
i've said that the in the original
problem itself the goods are indivisible
so the way you round this uh this
fractional perfect matching to a a real
perfect matching into an integral
perfect matching is to use the
the burkha von neumann theorem and
and that ensures that the expected
utility that each agent got from their
fractional
allocation is the same as what they got
after rounding okay so
okay so
everything is very nice and
the mechanism has a
wonderful uh
properties that come because of the
power of the pricing mechanism namely
pareto optimality and envy freeness and
incentive compatibility in the large
wonderful and that's why it was a
classic i mean nobody in economics wants
to ever
give up on this
and the the problem of course is that
it's intractable
and so intractable
that
at least i don't know of any way to
solve even a small problem with n equal
to say five
uh
without doing an exponential search over
the
space uh using algebraic cell
decomposition where every iteration
takes so much time
so i'm saying this is a very very
conservative estimate you cannot solve
anything more than n equal to 10
probably not more than n equal to six or
seven i don't know i don't know what end
but depends on how many mega computers
you throw at the problem obviously
so
uh what should we do it's it's totally
intractable
totally unusable
all the nice properties are worth uh
little in the in in the real world in
practice
okay
so
here uh we have proposed nash bargaining
based models
uh and so i first have to introduce to
you uh the nash bargaining problem
and the situation is that there are two
agents who process one good each let's
say a divisible good
and they want to
exchange fractionally these goods
okay and and you let s be
the set of all possible utilities
derived by these two agents
through all possible exchanges so on the
one extreme both goods are with one
agent on the other extreme both goods
are with the other agent and in between
are all other possibilities and the and
this is called the feasible set the set
s
and the property that we demand from the
set is that it should be convex and
compact which is not uh too much
okay
and uh besides this the problem
definition also has uh
the disagreement point which are the
utilities that the two agents get
uh by remaining at status quo so c1 is
what the first player got and c2 is what
the second player got by just when they
came to the to to do the bargaining and
obviously they will do the do the
exchange only if their solution lies in
this space
so c1 gets more one gets more than c1
and and two gets more than c2 then only
they'll do the exchange but the
important question is is which point to
pick in this region
okay
and here's where nash came in i think it
was okay oh yeah so nash gave four
axioms for for saying which point and
these are all important axioms for
optimality which we always like uh in
variance under affine transformation
symmetry that means you the naming of
the players should not affect the
solution independence of the relevant
alternative which is always nice also
no time to go into any of these details
but i hope you will read up on these if
you have if you don't know already and
most people would know already in this
community
so
so then came uh the wonderful theorem of
nash which is really really elegant so
beautifully done that there's a unique
solution
in in s that satisfies all four axioms
and it was given by maximizing this
product
uh v one minus c one times v two minus c
two where v two and v one and v two uh
this this uh vector v1 v2 lies
in the set s
and obviously it will be maximized uh at
at the boundary and so you'll get a
pareto optimal point because the
boundary is convex uh
uh
so
so you know yeah and also the rest of
the properties are satisfied in fact
it's through the properties that you
prove such a fantastic theorem
and in fact it works not only for two
agents but any number n of agents not
only that but
but because you're maximizing this
product if you take the log of this
product you get a concave function which
you are maximizing over convex set so
so the nash bargaining solution it's uh
is the optimal solution to a convex
program that already puts it in p
okay maybe at least to approximate it to
any given degree
uh
and so the very first thing that went
wrong with healing zacchaeuser looks
like we can do it and indeed we can so
we can define a linear fischer one-sided
matching market by by defining s to be
the utilities derived by the n agents in
all possible fractional perfect
matchings and let the nash bargaining
solution pick that the the unique point
at which the market will operate uh and
of course
yeah so here the disagreement utilities
are zero then there's the arrow
extension which is easy by taking the
disagreement you released to be initial
endowments and easily extends to
two-sided everything easily extends
experimentally we can solve n equal to
two thousand in one hour over a laptop
game theoretic properties come from nash
bargaining but then nv free is not
possible in this setting
and there's a new paper coming up where
we show proportionality at least one
over a two n fraction of of each uh
everybody will get at least one over two
and fraction of the total utility and if
you don't have unit demand constraints
which you have to have it will be one
over n which was a well-known result
from the past and it this is a
principled move because it really in a
deep way connects up
uh linear fissure setting
uh markets with uh nash bargaining and
the eisenberg guild convicts program and
and you can look up more details in the
paper because i've run out of time
and
the one question that we leave open is
other combinatorial algorithms with
proven gravities and this paper that i
mentioned give the first cut first
answer to this question but there are
i'm sure there'll be many more answers
to these this question and i hope many
more questions because there are so many
models to be studied here thank you
uh thank you very much bj so we're a bit
behind on time so we'll cut the
questions for uh for this and if the
next speaker can set up so if you can
stop sharing
uh and the next speaker is kindling
who's gonna tell us about
interactive communication bilateral
trade
um i'll start the timer uh the floor is
yours coming in
um
thanks
so uh i'm going to present however
interactive communication invalidator
retreat
it's a joint to work with jimmy mon
renato pass lemme from google and then
i'm borrowing the slides from renato
so we consider the bellator trade game
where we have sally and bob we have two
players
and sally is trying to sell one item to
bob
and sally has a private cost on that
item and bob has a private value on that
item
and india sally is going to choose the
price p
to price the item to bob
and then bob will accept the price if
his value is higher than or equal to p
and finally select the utility would be
the price minus for cost if the item is
sold and above the utility would be the
value minus price if the item is sold
and the intercepting from the revolution
principle we know that interaction is
not useful if the agents are strategic
and also from the medicine centers right
there and we know that we can't design
games that are always efficient meaning
that there would be cases where value is
higher than cost but
that's the agents
will not treat
however
that's actually not really the case in
reality for example we have jobs like
car dealers and real estate agents
that are primarily based on bargaining
so our goal of this work is to define
models of bilateral trade so that we can
capture this power of interactive
communication
so to that end we
introduced a new ingredient of the
classical model of basic persuasion
where we have a receiver and a sender
the sender knows some state of the world
data
but the receiver doesn't know the state
and in the end the receiver will take
some action
and then they will get the utilities
based on receiver section and the state
of the
and the persuasion part is in the
beginning the sender can send some
verifiable signal sigma that can be
correlated with the state of the board
to update
the receiver's perception of the state
so that upon receiving the signal the
receiver can choose the action to
maximize her expected utility given uh
she has received the signal signal
and there's a influential paper in the
setup by berger mandelbrook summaries
where they consider the setting where
sally is selling one item to bob
in their model sally has a fixed cost
but bob has a private value so
so in this model only bob has private
information
and in the end sally can choose some
action by increasing a price p and then
bob will accept if his value is higher
than or equal to p
so
for sally the
best price to set is to maximize this
price minus cost times the probability
of buying the item
and in their model they have this uh
in the beginning the bob can persuade
sally by sending a signal and this sigma
can be correlated with the value
so upon receiving that signal valley
will instead choose the p to maximize
price minus cost times the probability
of buying the item given he has sent the
signal sigma
and their main result is that there is a
way for bob to send the signal so that
the trade is efficient
meaning that if the value is higher than
a constant may be
and bob will be the one to capture the
remaining surplus from trade they said
and
we generalized their model so that steli
now also has a private information in
the form of her cost transformation
distribution
and we can still have the same model
where bob will send some signal to sell
it and instead it will send some price
but we can actually have an even more
general model
which we call basin conversation
where in the first step let's say sally
can send some signal sigma prime about
her private cost to bob
and then
after receiving that signal bob will
send something back to sally about his
private value
and finally said it will set some price
and we can generalize that thing into a
key round protocol where steli isn't
something about then about to sally and
so on until in the end steli will set a
press p
on the item
so
in this model
uh we consider the equilibrium concept
as the
imperfect match equilibrium so the
agents will
use backward induction to select their
optimal strategies in each step
and
in our model we
have two assumptions but the res each
receiver can always refuse to hear the
signal of the other player
and another assumption is that ties are
broken favorably to the other player
and for this model we can define this
message complexity so
for example if pi i t dsdb means the
utility for agent i you know p run
particle first we can show that the
utilities are always monotonically
increasing so that we can define the
limit of the utilities
and then we can define this message
complexity of a bilateral trade gain as
the minimum number of runs so that the
utilities will stop improving after that
point of p runs
and our main result of the paper is that
the agents won't stop communicating
until they have reached an efficient
allocation
in other words
if the message complexity of some game
is finite then it means we have reached
an efficient allocation so the utility
of the seller plus the utility of the
buyer because the maximum possible gains
from trade in the game
and the main open question in our work
is that
uh we have this conjecture that we
conjecture um the message complexity is
always valid if the distributions have
any support
in planetary
so if that's true it means uh
our interactive communication model will
always lead to efficiency infinitely
many steps
and if that's false it means other
settings where the agents would prefer
to
have an infinitely long conversation
they won't trade before having this
long conversation
in the yammer work we also have a set
result where if
bob's
valid distribution support has sent too
then
we fully characterize the communication
protocol and show that a two-round
protocol is enough for efficient trade
and uh
we conclude by
having the following message where a
long interactive communication can
improve outcomes and that often will
lead to efficiency
thanks for listening
great thanks uh and while kang kang uh
you know changes its lights i want to
ask quickly do you have any
uh
[Music]
do do you have any idea for this
conjecture
if it's true or false uh after thinking
about it
yeah i'll be actually think it should be
true by running some experiments
okay
so yeah in general uh
a very small number of rounds should be
enough for the better trade setting
but for the more general get me in our
work we also define the same setting for
marginal games and for more general
games we
ran experiment and it seems to be uh
the other with the other way that's uh
like the message complexity can be
infinity for family support
i see
all right thank you
uh
so if you can stop sharing and our last
speaker of today can
share your screen
thank you so our last speaker is uh
constantine zavarni from technion he is
going to be telling us about
multi-channel bayesian persuasion
uh take it away constantine
hello i'm constantine
and i'm going to talk about
multi-channel basic and persuasion this
is a joint work of jacob babichenko in
by the time coin and hyphen shu
there are many examples in which
a person tries to persuade a group of
agents to acting her favor by revealing
some partial information
one such typical situation is a
politician and trying to persuade voters
a standard mathematical model capturing
this situation and many others is called
the bayesian persuasion
and we've already seen a variation of
this model in the previous talk
and so in the general patient persuasion
model there's an agent called sender for
example the politician claims to
persuade some set of receivers for
example the voters
to act in the center's favor
they assume that each agent has a
utility function
and also there's a certain state
the value of which is known to the
sender but not to the receivers
however all the agents
have the same prior distribution on the
values of the state
and a possible example of a state is
that the depositions plan
before observing the value of the state
the sender should strategically commit
to an information revolution policy such
as a political campaign
and we call this a policy a signaling
scheme
the current patent persuasion literature
mostly assumes a dichotomy either the
sender
may communicate with each receiver via a
private communication channel and this
model is unsurprisingly called the
private persuasion
or the sender must transmit the same
signal to all the receivers
and this model is a public persuasion
however in many reef applications it is
reasonable to assume
that the sender can communicate with
different subsets of folders or in
general receivers
via
different communication channels
and this is the model we study in our
paper
let's demonstrate our setting
graphically
through an example so here we have a
three states with prior probabilities
0.3.5 and 0.2
we also have 4 receivers and three
communication channels red green and
purple
first of all the sender commits to a
signaling scheme
which tells for any possible state
which combination of signals to send
through the channels with which
probability
after committing a
to the civilian scheme
a state is drawn from the proud
distribution and is reported to the
sender upon
receiving the state
and
the true state together of the civilian
scheme specify the signals the sender
transmits through all the channels
and each receiver
observes the channels
which are sent
through the relevant uh
estrella communication channel so for
example here
a receiver one observes only a sigma one
the receiver two absorbs all the three
signals
upon observing the relevant signals each
receiver updates her belief about the
distribution of the state
uh to a certain posterior distribution
using basis law
and then each receiver takes an action
aiming to maximize her expected utility
over the posterior distribution of the
states
and finally
each agent
both the sender and the receivers get
utilities which depend generally on the
true state and on the actions of all the
receivers
in bayesian persuasion uh the center is
the designer and
and therefore
normally the research focuses on helping
the sender
to choose an expected utility maximizing
a signaling scheme
and
in our paper study the most general base
and persuasion setting
by a loving arbitrary structure of
communication channels as well as the
arbitrary functions of both the sender
and the receivers and the also arbitrary
power distribution
also our model captures the receivers
who have externalities
which means that
the actions of the receivers affect each
other
our main research question in this paper
is as follows
when one communication structure is
better for the sender than another in
the robust sense the robustness means
that the center's preferences should
hold
regardless of both of the utilities of
the sender and the receivers and also
regardless of the prior distribution
and a previous work of by bertien perego
studies an analogous questions in a
slightly different setting
to present our main result let's
introduce a simple notion of information
dominance
if we say it when receiver information
dominates another receiver
if the first one observes at least the
same communication channels as the
second one
so in this example
receiver 4 is information dominated by
receiver 3 because the receiver 4
absorbs only the purple channel but
receiver 3 also observes the purple
channel on the other hand a receiver 2
observes all the 3 channels and
therefore she information dominates all
the other receivers
our main result is that the
accommodation structure m1
is better for the standard than another
structure m2 regardless of the parallel
distribution and the utility functions
if and only if every information domain
pairs of receivers in m1 is also an
information automatic pair of receivers
in m2
intuitively each information dramatic
pair of receivers
imposes restrictions on how much the
sender
can miscorrelate the signals embedded to
different receivers
and it turns out that such stick shards
are a
the only restrictions
and quite surprisingly the proof is
based on a secret sharing protocols from
cryptography
one
important special case
is that
in a communication structure without any
information domain pairs of receivers
such as this example in the slide with
six receivers and four communication
channels
uh the sender can implement private
persuasion
and in particular private persuasion is
that the best possible communication
structure for the sender because it's
the most flexible and
it's the most flexible communication
structure
it also follows from our main result
that
a number of channels which is
logarithmic in the number of receivers
suffices for the sender to implement
private persuasion which is an
exponential improvement uh compared to
the implementation of private persuasion
and also our construction achieves the
information theoretical overbound on the
number of channels required to implement
private persuasion and not only
asymptotically but also exactly
and we also prove two computational
results
on the positive side we provide an
additive fbi
for a natural family of communication
structures and additives and there's
utilities
here we only focus on a constant number
of states because it is known from a
previous literature
that
for a general number of states even
public persuasion even a swimming
additives and versatility is hard to
approximate
on the negative side
we provide a general family of centres
utilities for which both a private
public persuasion are computationally
retractable
but general mutual persuasion is the np
heart
the main takeaway from this paper is a
simple characterization of a partial
ordering override communication
structures
by the center's preferences in the
robust sense
the robustness means that the
preferences hold regardless of the
utilities of all the agents and the
prior distribution
if we study some natural special cases
but of course many other
interesting cases exist
and it would be nice to understand uh
the life applications of our model
and one specific case which one may
study
is the fixing certain utility functions
for the agents and providing the sender
with some communication structure
but allowing the sender and
to perform changes to the communication
structure under some constraints for
example
to add the limited number of
communication channels and the question
would be
whether it's computationally tractable
to understand
the optimal standards behavior in such a
setting
thank you very much for your attention
great so uh a big round of applause to
all our speakers
uh one quick question constantin while
you're still here so could you give some
intuition as to why
uh multi-channel is harder than both
private and public persuasion
ah yes so i can tell you all the the
functions because so there is a super
majority a function yes which
assumes that each receiver has only two
actions and if the number of resilient
induction done is then above a certain
threshold then
the selected till dividend is zero so
when we take weighted average of such
functions over a partition of receivers
then it is easy to show that it is
tractable for both public and private
prostration but not for general
persuasion yes and
and the reduction is from the uh from
the minimum union problem
i see
okay okay that's very clever thank you
very much
another round of applause to our
speakers thanks again for being so
accommodating everyone and uh sorting
out the technical difficulties that we
had
uh thanks to our speakers and uh
there should be a link to gather
you know if you want to have more
one-on-one questions or things like this
thank you everyone